after watching the last video on
corporations and limited liability you
might be asking yourself was that fair
if bill had owned the the cab himself
and got sued the soccer player whose
career was ruined would have gotten his
actual million dollars but because bill
set up this corporation and put the
assets of the cab company in this
corporation he was able to limit his
liability the soccer player was only
able to get $180,000 the corporation
declared bankruptcy but Bill's liability
was limited to what he had contributed
to the corporation and he might say my
god this guy over here his life was
somewhat ruined and he's not able to
kind of get compensated for I guess how
bad his life was ruined and Bill is so
rich Bill is so rich he could probably
still make money he should give him the
money so you should say you know this is
kind of an unfair way that these
corporations are a way for well-off
people or wealthy people to protect
their assets and to some degree that's
true but I want to think about in this
video is kind of the trade-offs and
really this is just a balance that
society has to pick that this really was
on at least the way I had set it up in
the last video it was kind of unfair to
the soccer player I mean he was only
getting $180,000 for something that
might have ruined his career but if you
had talked to Bill bill might have said
well you know that's right
corporations are kind of limiting
liability for someone like me but he'd
say look I wouldn't have started or you
know maybe he wouldn't have started the
cab company if he didn't have that
limited liability he said look if I had
all of these assets maybe maybe he had a
million dollars maybe he had up or
actually meet here he does have a
million dollars maybe had a hundred
million dollars he said look if I had a
hundred million dollars and I didn't
have the option of starting a
corporation I would not have started a
cab company because just for a little
bit of small profit that I could have
gotten from an eighty thousand dollar
cab I wouldn't have wanted to just
jeopardize my the rest of my empire so
if I didn't have limited liability I
wouldn't have started the business to
begin with and that would not have been
good for society another argument bill
might make and I'm not going to take
sides here I'm just saying these are
these are the balance these
the things that you have to weigh when
you set up a legal code in a society is
that bill said look whoever starts a cab
business this cab business that you know
roughly you could start with eighty
ninety or a hundred thousand dollars
they all have the same upside they're
taking a certain amount of risk they're
providing a service to the city they'll
probably make a similar amount of money
and he would argue that it would be
unfair that we have different downsides
maybe maybe Sal right over here
maybe Sal right here maybe my only
assets are the cab Plus licenses and I
have a TK over there and the insurance
and the insurance which is 1k and so
what bill would say is look me and Sal
could both open the exact same cab
business and if there were no
corporations if I had to oh if I had to
own I want to say I am talking about
Bill if Bill had to own the assets of of
the cab company or I shouldn't say the
cab company I should say bill had to
directly own the assets the cab and
licenses even though bills and sales up
side from the business the profit they
could make would be the same bills
downside would be more because he has he
if he didn't have the corporation he
would have all of these other assets at
risk and maybe that would make bill get
a bigger policy instead of $100,000
policy maybe he would want to get a
million dollar policy and then a million
dollar policy will probably cost ten
times more it would cost ten thousand
dollars to have that policy and so if
you view it from that way in order to
protect his other assets his cost of
business would be higher just because he
happens to have other things and so bill
might argue hey that wouldn't be fair it
would again be a reason why someone with
assets would be would be less inclined
to start another business which may not
be great for society and then the other
thing that bill might argue is that look
in exchange for limited liability he
might have to be double taxed and this
is an interesting discussion here
because you'll probably hear this term a
lot double taxation double double
taxation it's not it's it's not
necessarily going to happen but if
the large corporation the type of
corporations that are publicly traded
this will happen and the idea behind
double corporate double taxation it's
not true for all corporations and that's
a fact let me differentiate it double
taxation happens with AC corporation a C
Corp it does not happen with things
called s corpse and I'm not going to go
in detail here and what these are s
corpse LLC which stands for limited
liability corporation LPS which stands
for limited partnerships or limited
liability partnerships ll P's it doesn't
apply to any of these things but what
happens in double taxation is that let's
say you have some corporation some C
Corp and let's say that it makes let's
say it makes $1,000 in profit so it
makes $1,000 in profit in a given year
that since this is being treated as kind
of a legal entity that's kind of like a
person by the government it gets taxed
like a person so they're going to have
to pay some tax maybe it's let's say 30
percent tax so they're going to have to
pay 30% or 35% or whatever the corporate
tax the marginal corporate tax rate for
this corporation is going to be so
they're going to have to pay three
hundred dollars three hundred dollars in
taxes and then let's say this
corporation whatever it has left over
after taxes so this is let me make it
clear this is pre-tax pre-tax profit it
pays 30% to the government and so it has
$700 and so it has $700 in net net
income so this is net of taxes and
everything and let's say it then
dividends that out to its shareholders
so then it gives it to its shareholders
to its shareholders and let's just say
for simplicity there's one shareholder
so one shareholder but this is true even
if there were more than one shareholders
so that one shareholder he's getting
$700 in income based on the fact that he
owns this corporation he is going to
have to pay taxes again so that $700 so
he has to pay taxes so let me do it this
way let me draw it he has to pay taxes
again maybe his marginal tax rate is
another three
80% so he'll have to pay 30% to the
government again so this is 30% on the
$700 so he'll pay 210 210 dollars in
taxes to the government based on this
net income from his dividend that he's
getting out from the C corporation and
actually I want to be very careful here
I don't want to get into the details but
dividends can sometimes be taxed
differently than straight-up income but
just for the sake of simplicity let's
say it's 30% it might be a lower or
higher amount but this is the idea of
double taxation the corporation is you'd
as a legal entity it pays taxes and then
whatever and then after those taxes it's
able to give its money back to
shareholders and then those shareholders
have to pay money on that income again
so that's what the double taxation is
and regardless you know some people say
hey this is horribly unfair you know why
should you have to pay taxes twice on
the same money and then some of argue
well look you're getting all of this
limited liability if you don't like
paying those double taxes don't set up a
corporation and then just accept the
full straight-up liability so it's a
trade-off you pay the double taxes you
get the limited liability and let me be
clear here
this applies mainly the large
corporations if you want the limited
liability but you don't want to have to
do this double taxation any of these
other corporate structures are available
and these are usually available to
smaller less complicated companies I
should say then what's going on with the
C Corp and an S corp you have a limited
number of shareholders LLC's they can't
last forever they they stopped lasting
as soon as one of the partners of the
corporation one of the owners of the
corporation pass away or declare
bankruptcy so there are limitations here
but these do get the benefits of limited
liability limited liability and the
profits get passed through to the owners
without getting taxed first and so they
also have single taxation single
taxation so going back to the fairness
issue if Bill was smart when he started
this company he probably would set this
up as a limited liability corporation or
as an S corporation or something where
he doesn't have to get double taxed and
still he would of
Wade having to pay the soccer player the
full million dollars just what just
whatever the company has that's all the
soccer player would get but let's say
the car service becomes huge and he
wants to make it public one day then he
would have to make it a c-corporation
and then he would have to do the whole
double taxation but it's something to
think about you know it's an interesting
to think about is it fair to have
something like this the the the pro
corporation side is it encourages
entrepreneurship people won't worry
about the downside as much people it
kind of levels the playing field in
terms of regardless of however many side
assets you have you have the same
liability for a certain amount of
business and there's usually certain
rules that you have to have a certain
amount of money in the corporation a
certain amount of insurance in the
corporation if you don't then possibly
the court can go after the owners assets
but as long as you maintain it in a
responsible well capitalized way
probably won't and then the other
trade-off is this double taxation thing
that at least for large corporations the
type that you know the the general
electric's and the and the you know the
googles and the Microsoft's of the
worlds they are they do pay a fee for
this limited liability and that's in and
that's in terms of this double taxation
all those smaller corporations right
when they're getting started out or kind
of partnerships they don't have the
double taxation but they do get the
limited liability